let's start over this is really good
stuff if that were you mr vlad do you
have president vladimir putin if that
were annalynne mccord you probably would
have been like oh yeah they're the eyes
of course
the eyes are red aren't they look at
that one of them winked look at that
hi dev yeah
dear president vladimir putin
i'm so sorry that i was not your mother
if i was your mother you would have been
so loved
held in the arms of joyous light
never would the stories plight the world
unfurled before our eyes a pure demise
of nations sitting peaceful under a
night sky if i was
the world would have been warm
so much laughter and joy and nothing
would harm i can't imagine the stain the
soul-stealing pain that the little boy
you must have seen and believed and the
formulation of thought quickly taught
that you live the rhythm is so like it's
it's it's literally deaf poetry jam yeah
it's it's a slam poetry she thinks she
yeah she thinks it's like i'm gonna i'm
gonna reach the people through slam
poetry
there's still two minutes and they
quickly taught that you lived in a cruel
unjust world
steal her whole poem
their entire poem front
no it's [ __ ] original i wrote in my
[ __ ] cell if i was your chum
why would you charm my patch on about i
want to get that uh
maybe i could get the uh transcript of
that i have a feeling somebody's gonna
be posting that soon well yeah i think
uh
i think yeah a producer for a certain
podcast could probably help you out
unfoiled
yeah you do the words wrong dude
unfurled
quickly taught
is this why
you now decide no one will get the best
of you
is this why you do not hide nor away shy
from taking
[Music]
there's no way you can get through that
line without cringing
nor away shy
no one talks like that
no one has ever spoken like way shy
and at its core
the point of this is
i could have stopped putin with my love
how sheep thought i i wrote that when i
was 18 in my shitty poem
the one that kevin smith read on the air
how sheep thought i still i stole from
clockwork orange
he yanked it right oh did i thanks stan
right off the [ __ ] page i took it oh
not even from the movie i don't remember
probably
oh so but norah wait oh please let's
keep going i can't uh
so early in life all that strife wraps
your little body with fear
if i was your mother if the world was
cold i'd have died to make you warm i'd
have died to protect you from the unjust
the violence the terror the uncertainty
i would have died to give you life oh
dear mr president putin only might be
your mother
[Music]
perhaps the torture of unread youth
would not within your heart and view a
scripture to such fealty against that
world
i don't even know what field he is
fealty
uh it was used i'll tell you one time
i've heard it
in little murders donald sutherland used
it
fealty
uh a scripture to such fealty but i
don't know what it means i like the word
and the fact
that she put an apostrophe instead of an
a and put against
i think
means
strength or fortitude is that what it
means something i believe it means
something like that
against
fealty against or like or or
solidarity
against fortitude strength yeah
that means she wanted her syllables to
have the most impact humanly it's old
it's it's stealing
old world
poetry kind of
loyalty to a lord oh but did i oh formal
acknowledgement of loyalty to a lord
i was completely wrong i thought she
might not know the word either yeah uh
within your heart to be a description
she hasn't said a scripture in real life
guilty is defined as she's never used
the word description something owed to a
very powerful person by someone okay who
is loyal that's true uh a scription to
to fealty uh that means like yeah such
as what a description a scription to
such fields it's when you're sick you go
to doctor when you're five kind of
scripture
yeah i got can i get uh a scription yeah
what does description mean i don't know
i think a scription to such fealty
adhesion yeah it would yeah it would
kind of i think mean that like you're
you you tend to
do things out of loyalty a lot a
scription the attribution of something
to a cause
right it would come from a scribe right
the root just describes
it definitely sucks all right let's
let's play i want to hear the against
again against such field against against
against
to such fealty against that oh and she
said it was so cool
perhaps you would hold dear human life
and on this night instead of mother
russia you would call me
oh my god set your mind quite free with
the love that only a mother can give
and only a mother can take away
ooh
when holds she doesn't harm at bay and
leaves her boy for the promise of a man
whatever your story mr president putin
i can't imagine but hip-hop oh yeah oh
oh is it the
there's this moment
where she's acting like she's moving her
mouth like she's trying to find the
words
for a poem that she's clearly written
and rehearsed many many times and is
reading right now she is literally
reading right now you do not have to
search for words when the paper is in
front of you and she's also i think
she's also trying to make it look like
there's emotion here yes go back just a
little let's let's start to see the
emotion about to pour out and leave
only a man whatever can you picture
putin going we have to invade ukraine
well mom
you don't think so mom what do you think
i just need a hug
what a sheltered view yeah it really is
it's a sheltered dumb view you know what
you know all he needs is a hug you know
what
white privilege
god damn it blm is right this is white
privilege suck this is a hundred percent
white privilege we stink
can you imagine thinking that there's so
much plight in the world if only there
was a hug like no [ __ ] there's a lot
more going on
yeah my hug she wants to be the mother
she knows the cure jim it might even he
might even have a wonderful relationship
with his mother
yeah very warm i don't know anything
about it his mother might have suggested
it what are you doing you ever think
your brother would have invaded already
but then anal mccord would tell you
that's because i wasn't his mother
you see
it's not just any mother
story mr president putin
i can't imagine she's trying to feign
emotion she's fainting
i can't imagine
it
it's not real and leaves her boy for the
promise of a man whatever your story mr
president putin
i can't imagine how it feels in your
heart but i know if i was your mother
yeah that would be a start
oh towards the awareness yeah right
more like you'd be a fart yeah or a
shart yeah
yes
there's plenty of better stuff to rhyme
there yep
wouldn't that be great if you were
dating her and you're like one
correction what if instead of start you
said sharks
[Laughter]
towards the awareness of what a powerful
being of light you could be if your mind
was only free from the violence you've
seen when you were just two or three i
can't believe i was born too late
in a different place when i would have
loved you so
watched you play wherever you go
and then it ends it just cuts off yeah
twitter was like it's enough
it's just enough
she thinks if she had been vladimir
putin's mother she would have run to a
playground and then he wouldn't have
invaded the ukraine if you were
president
what would you do oh for george floyd
she did it are people going back through
her videos now oh poor analym accord oh
what's the [ __ ] what's the derrick
chauvin one
she's not good with the edit no what
look
[Laughter]
you know what
she is [ __ ] she's
hot she's gorgeous
and that's why nobody tells you these
are bad ideas yeah i feel like i you
know you have to wonder if she knows if
she can tolerate my side fat and tits i
could put up with her poems
that's how it would work out
officer derek
i would have brought a press conference
and
i would have sat down across from him
and i would have said
i'm so sorry officer wow okay let's see
i'm so glad that pause was there i'm so
glad the pause was there because it's
like oh what kind of venom
what kind of hatred
what kind
i'm so sorry you're the problem is she
has delusions of grandeur it's of
wanting
to be important it's of wanting to be
heard of wanting to be like but not
having the awareness to go like everyone
kind of has this [ __ ] inside of them
we really do all have a bit of this but
most of us just don't write a poem
because you you
you cringe you make fun of yourself
for it but does she want she probably
fantasies this all the time if i was
president what would i say
yeah exactly that she would have stopped
it from happening because she probably
thinks she's actually probably right if
she would have if she would have been
there and and [ __ ] derek shover would
have seen her he probably been like oh
[ __ ] it's cher
and gotten off his neck that's probably
true probably probably just out of pure
shock like what did what is cher doing
here it's it's when these actresses or
people in public life try so hard to
have them all you can have opinions but
it's when they try so hard to hit the
emotional home run
think about the amount of people there
are in poor analyn mccord's life
that will put up
with so much nonsense
because she is so beautiful is there any
positive reviews of that first poem we
just heard this one i don't want to hear
this one i can't i can't i can't yeah no
i can't i can't i can't
but like
if you were dating her no the other one
are there any positive reviews of the of
the uh
of the putin promo oh i'm sure that's do
you think people are loving it
okay there's 40 000 comments on it oh
boy generally that's a good sign check
the quote yeah well yeah
it's a good oh a hundred thousand quote
tweets
honestly it's such a weird ass claim to
want to be his mother did you want to
breastfeed baby vladimir why would you
say that somebody had another comment
about the soviet situation
[ __ ] you his mother worked in a factory
for scraps of food to feed her kid
during the time of the soviets you would
be moaning about it [ __ ] even had
aborted a baby at that time
uh what an ever loving [ __ ]
oh
wow now jim as i look at the quote
tweets look at me look at me yeah it
really there's not a lot of positive
ones look at me look at me yeah it's
it's uh
i mean some people when we say poignant
things at least have their this hamilton
2 trailer sucks
this is honestly the most hilarious
thing on the internet right now peak
hollywood yeah brian simpson oh we're
having him soon oh that's great how is
he coming in yeah yeah he's a funny
comic yeah i uh
yes girl boss blame women for a dictator
causing a whole war
his mother probably did work at a
factory during the old soviet time yeah
his mother probably did not have a lot
look at me look at me
wow
no positives oh
and and again the lack of awareness to
just take it down and go
oh let's see let's see she explains her
viral vladimir putin poem oh good
uh she says
i know i could have easily moved in the
direction of becoming a dictator myself
oh
mccord told buzzfeed news when asked
about the video which has since gone
viral if certain circumstances of my
life were different were i a little less
bent toward healing
oh and more toward vindication
i could have been a darkly powerful
person
wow delusions of grandeur and it's a lie
by the way that's not the motive of her
poem the motive of her poem is attention
and making something about herself and
getting some type of credit for
emotionally
saying what did what needed to be said
that was the motive for the poem i don't
know jim sometimes i feel like
if my brain like my brain is wired to
talk about like wrestling but if my
brain were more wired to talk about like
politics i'd probably be the president
and by the way here's another lie she
added that she hopes to raise awareness
about the changes needed within the
education system to protect children and
creating dictators and abusers and
enslavers and rapists and bullies among
other things no it was like she hopes to
raise awareness about herself yeah
that's always that's raising awareness
about you i'd like to raise awareness of
the fact that i'm on the planet be
truthful about it
but she's i mean i think she
she's got some stuff going on anybody
that gets that kind of feedback on a
project and is still
feet dug in the ground no here's why i
did it and just doesn't like there is no
aha moment none zero there's something
going on in her brain it's just a lack
of self-awareness like an extreme lack
of self-awareness though yeah when you
when you're that beautiful and i'm sure
she's a good actress so when you're that
beautiful and people always tell you how
incredible you are
it is probably uncomfortable to
to to look behind that and go oh no like
you don't want to see it she was great
in 90210 yeah i'm sure she's great again
to work i'm sure it's fine but the cw
reboot
i don't know any of these other projects
but i can tell you this wow
90210 was a hell of a reboot
oh she's in powerbook uh she's in power
nope no power book power book three
power books raising yeah yeah no i know
but that's oh it's power book three book
three right that's how they name their
show
i got you that's weird there should be a
colon after power i agree it should be
because i didn't know what it was i see
that's forks i love joe sakura yeah so i
see all those ads for on stars
but um
whatever the power show he's doing but
yeah they should put a colon after that
where's uh
the 90210 reboot should be on this list
somewhere i guess it was longer ago than
i thought it was oh she was on the
dallas reboot too that's very very
exciting yeah oh shot jr there you go
2008 to 2013. 114 episodes it was sick
i watched them all i'm sure
it was great i watched it live
as it happened